hello everyone and welcome to today's
live broadcast clinical core lab design
from looking up to looking down
presented by tammy gemiini director lab
operations at Geisinger Medical Center
I'm Suzy Valdez of lab roost and I'll be
your moderator for today's event
we're looking to be excited to bring you
this educational web seminar presented
by lab roots the leading scientific
social networking website and provider
of virtual events and webinars before we
begin I'd like to remind everyone that
this presentation is interactive we want
to hear from you so questions comments
can be submitted via the green Q&A
button at the lower left of your screen
once there as many questions as we have
time for at the end of the presentation
also you're viewing the presentation in
a slide window to enlarge that window
click on the icon at the lower
right-hand corner of the slide window if
you cannot hear or see this presentation
properly let us know by clicking on the
support button at the top right or the
Q&A button and let us know that you're
having a problem I will now turn the
presentation over to Tammy Germany
welcome in this Tammy Germany I am the
director of laboratory operations that
guide to Singer Medical Center I feel
very privileged to be with you today so
thank you for having me
we were very fortunate at Geisinger
Medical Center to be able to develop a
brand new laboratory medicine building
and with that was fortunate enough to
install some of the Roche equipment and
that's what's bringing me here today to
talk about our experience that we have
so Geisinger is located in central
Pennsylvania we serve about 44
Pennsylvania County and have eight
hospital or medical centers that we
partner with or actually own and then we
have 66 primary care and specialty
clinics so of course the evolution of
laboratory medicine is what
brings us into our future state and what
we needed to be able to be successful in
the future so historically we had very
manual processes lifetimes we had
beakers of liquids we had specimens and
compounds that we would have to
manipulate on countertops but in the
future State and where we are today we
have more automation and this is
important for us to be able to have a
facility that allows us to move forward
with changes that may happen all of you
out in the laboratory business certainly
are aware of the fact that we are
changing constantly not just our
instrumentation that our workflows so it
was important to us as we were
developing this building to establish a
way that we could be flexible and that's
what you're going to see as I move
forward today so for us at Geisinger we
wanted to respond to all the changes
that were happening we wanted to design
that lab that was capable of
accommodating all of those ongoing
changes so as we develop this new
medical lab design we had certain goals
in mind one of them was to incorporate
lab based solutions to address factors
driving our practice change the second
was to design a flexible structure in
support of an ever-shifting lab
environment and laugh to understand the
factors that influence the need for a
flexible lab so what are some of those
factors that are driving the change
these are those common forces that look
that we need to look at to be able to
adapt appropriately so looking at a
space constraint I can't speak for
everyone across the country but I've
certainly worked in laboratories in
North Carolina and Pennsylvania and one
of the things that we deal with our
small amount of footprint and this is
the space that we have is limited by
what is available time sometimes it's a
closet sometimes it's a small office
room so we need to be able to decide as
we built this building what to do with
the footprint we're always focused on
improving our patient care health care
is a constant changing environment and
we have to be able to move forward with
whatever changes in regulatory agencies
or government or just our own healthcare
system needs to place the focus on the
next is stepping constraints second
third shift and weekends frequently have
less staff available than during the day
so we need to be able to be flexible in
how we're able to provide the best
patient care utilizing a minimum amount
of staffing the other constraint that
we've run into and I know we're
experiencing it across the nation is a
low amount of technologists that are
graduating with a high number of
technologists that are retiring so we
need to be able to figure out how to
function with less staffing and that was
one of the factors that we were
considering mitigating space staffing
and workflow design this is finding that
balance making it less painful for us
from the space the staffing and a
workflow design we also have changes in
volumes and instrumentation so for
example we have samples that we'll send
out for testing but as that volume
increases we decide that we should be
doing them in-house so and we change
that we may need additional
instrumentation we may need additional
staffing but whatever the needs arise we
have to deal with those so those were
one of the factors that we need to take
into consideration
when building the building lien
assessments are looking at that constant
continuous improvement opportunity and
any changes in workflows that may come
with that it's important for us at
Geisinger to focus on lien and making
sure that we're providing the most
efficient and productive environment
that we can so we look to our staff to
be able to give us ideas on how to
change our workflows and it's important
that as we go forward with that we
provide an environment that is conducive
to allowing us to make those changes and
then finally turnaround time providing
the best patient care for us in the
laboratory typically revolves around
turnaround time now here at Geisinger we
actually look at our staff testing
performed from collection to result in
less than 60 minutes now ideally we like
to meet that in 90 percent of the time
so for us it was imperative that we
consider that as a part of our building
planning so our flexibility essentials
you know those common forces that
looking at changes in the last
reconfiguration of our casework
equipment and instruments to accommodate
additional work spaces or technologists
or to reorganize in a more efficient
manner so for us as we were designing
the building it was imperative that we
had that flexibility so I'll show you a
little bit further in the presentation
how we were able to take our tabletops
and be able to move them to different
locations take our instrumentation and
move them to different locations with
minimal impact to the structure of the
building a spatial organization so we
can accommodate a new operational model
such as moving from the part mentalize
layout to an open lab plan so historic
we in our old building we were in rooms
and we had walls all the way around our
rooms and in our new floor plan we
developed a open floor plan concept so
there were no wall and this was
important for us to be able to grow into
the future so we had to deal with where
does where does our electrical or data
or plumbing come in so spatial
organization was important so ultimately
leading to our infrastructure changes so
the plumbing electrical etc has to be
adapted to this equipment and instrument
and any of the casework bring
reconfigurations that we may have so
historically labs were designed kind of
looking up so our services and utilities
came down from the CLA so I will point
briefly at the first area on my slide so
we had service columns so for example
you'll see right here will excuse me
right here as a service column so all of
the electrical and the data the plumbing
would be coming down from these
electrical columns the next was the
ceiling panel this was another type of
design that was available to most
laboratories and this was an example of
where the electrical or data or even the
gas lines were all coming out of the
ceiling not in a column but just via
some lines and as you can see that's
quite messy and I'll very distracting to
the work environment and then the other
type that was available historically
were ceiling structures so you can see
how there was a hanging rectangle that
came down and it was almost more of all
of the electrical and data just hanging
from the ceiling all of these were very
difficult to
maneuver around they were nicely in meat
from up in the ceiling however you could
still see the cords
coming down so as we designed our
laboratory we wanted to look more
towards looking down so our services and
utilities come from the floor this
really allowed us a lot more flexibility
if I go back for just a moment to the
previous slide you'll see that each of
these were designed so that they're just
in one space
they weren't easily moved the design we
developed in our building was to put
them in the floor and allows us to have
what's called a raised access floor so
from the points that you see here is 18
inches above where the concrete floor
actually is located and that space in
between is where all of our electrical
data and plumbing is positioned so by
having the raised floor we can actually
pick up some of the tile and we can get
down below and move any of that
electrical or data of plumbing to
accommodate new instrumentations
new technologies or new workflows that
we may develop this has been very
beneficial to us so this kinda shows you
a picture of what that raised floor
looks like and I'll take a quick block
to show you what area I'm talking about
right now what you see here is the
access floor that would be where the
instruments or the people will be
walking on the next area shows you the
service utilities that are all running
in between that access floor and debate
concrete floor and then of course you'll
see over to the side any of the casework
and equipment this access has been very
beneficial to us we have been in our
building now for approximately two years
it'll be two years this summer to be
exact and we have found that we've
already experienced some new
technologies and a couple of new
workflows that allow us the opportunity
to move around some of this data and
electrical and plumbing and it was very
simple for us to do so so we're very
fortunate that we've been able to truly
already experience the benefits of
having the raised floor what you see
here is also some of the modular
casework that we have in our laboratory
this casework is easily mobile we can
move it around any direction we need to
to address any changes in our workflows
or if we get new equipment we may need
to change where it's located by having
the access floor we can also access any
of the electrical data or plumbing from
any location so by moving around this
casework we can also access that data
electrical or plumbing from any location
so here's an example of where we have
changed once we moved into the
laboratory you'll see our before States
over here on the left hand side and I
will highlight that for you for just a
moment you will see we have our
pneumatic tube station up in the left
hand corner we have four tables here in
the middle that we did our work and then
over here on the left hand side is where
we did our blood gases excuse me we
still do our blood gases but that was
the original configuration we had a lean
consultant come in
and evaluate our work processes because
we found that on our new instrumentation
it was very easy for us to meet the
turnaround times of the testing this is
the receipt to result portion what we
were struggling with is the time the
sample was received into the laboratory
till the time we put it on the
instrument so we felt like it was
important that we evaluate that workflow
and the lien consultant made a number of
recommendations based on her
observations so in our after excusing
our after section you'll see that we
made some significant changes so here we
used to have the four tables that were
set just side by side we changed that to
a u-shape so that we could have our
staff a little bit closer to our
pneumatic tube system and could allow
for some flexibility in where the staff
was sitting depending on when excuse me
where they were pulling samples out of
the pneumatic tube we also allowed for a
change in where the casework was placed
so if you will notice where I mentioned
we were doing blood gases before we now
move that table from over in the right
hand side to the left hand side and that
allows a more open concept for the
technologists to come in and out a very
quickly we also added a sink to that
area because we were spending a lot of
time walking further away from receiving
the tubes into the receiving and
processing area so we were able to dump
say ice that came down in the bag or if
we had some extra urine specimens and a
20-4 container we didn't have to walk so
far away to dump that out either
so another opportunity that we had to
make a design change was prior to the
end of construction we were very
fortunate we were able to purchase new
equipment prior to the end of
construction however we were already in
the development stages of designing the
lab and actually the first two floors of
the building had actually completed
construction by the time we had made the
decision on our new equipment that we
were going to be bringing into our
building hey excuse me
so our architects of course have the
opportunity to redesign our space and
where our instruments were located and
as you can imagine this could have been
a huge obstacle because of the fact that
construction had already started so the
before state is on your left hand side
here and you will see that we had in
purple some of our automated chemistry
hematology and coagulation equipment
that was now going to be incorporated to
our new automation line when we designed
the new facility we knew we wanted to
open for concepts so luckily that worked
to our advantage as we were moving in
this new piece of equipment and
designing where it would be located so
as you'll see in the after pictures we
have this section here that we moved
from east to west north to south and had
minimal changes in the way the
electrical and data and plumbing needed
to be redesigned simply because we've
had the raised floor and it was
conveniently located in the same general
area so there was minimal impact to the
design of
the building for the new placement of
the equipment now we did originally have
designed over here on the left hand side
some semi automated testing and we flip
that down to this bottom section here as
you'll see by by just simply moving some
of the casework that was originally
going to be in the building we also
changed some of the electrical and
plumbing and data but again minimal
impact because of the raised floor made
it very convenient to simply move things
around a little bit so in summary we
have some evolving testing technology
ever changing within the laboratory
environment I know all of you
experienced this unfortunately that can
truly impact us when you have concrete
floor walls that may or may not allow
you the space for you to be able to
introduce a new piece of equipment into
something as simple as a doorway to be
able to get the equipment into the
building or into a specific room really
provides a significant space constraint
that a lot of people struggle to deal
with so we were very fortunate when we
developed the building we now have that
flexible response that as we have these
changes we won't have to have walls
busted down or major construction for
the flooring so that's a benefit to us
and met one of the objectives that we
were looking at when designing the
building we moved away from that
traditional distribution of services
looking up so we don't have to worry
about the eyesore of the various tubing
or plugs that are hanging from the
ceiling we don't have a limitation
from where those columns were from old
spaces that we had to deal with we have
that new approach of looking down at our
raised floor and that flooring allows us
such flexibility that we can really
change as the future brings it to us in
our old building we were literally in
the hundred-year-old portion of the
building and had been there that long so
we would expect that we will spend the
next hundred plus year in our new
building that will allow us such
flexibility that as technology and what
was changed we won't have to worry about
a large expense that we will have to
contribute to making those changes and
then designing flexibility so all of the
opportunities that we have with our
casework makes it possible for us to
change with the work force to our
casework is frequently on wheels so it's
very easy to move and then the race
floor of course adding that
functionality that's easy so not only
does it allow for ease but it also
allows for limited dish disruption and
allowing us to make a quick change as I
had shown you before that receiving and
processing area where we made those
changes all of that was done in less
than a day and if we had been in another
facility or even our old lab space
unfortunately we would have had to have
significant downtime and potential major
construction that would have limited the
schedule and the cost associated with
that I want to take this time to thank
you for having me and open it up for any
questions that you may have
thank you for your informative
presentation Tammy and for such valuable
details we want to get right to the
questions and input from our audience so
here's a reminder for audience members
about how you can communicate with us
questions can be submitted via the Q&A
button at the lower left if we are
unable to get to your questions due to
time restraints Tammy will reach out via
email let's turn to our first audience
questions our first question is the
raised access floor design seems very
beneficial is that throughout the entire
lab and what would be the cost for
creating such an addition to a lab all
right we do have limitations on where it
is on the other floors
so our building is actually three floors
we have our patient access areas on the
first floor so for example lab
collections in apheresis our second
floor is anatomic pathology and our
third floor is clinical pathology so our
first and second floor does not have the
raised floor it's only on the third
floor it is throughout the core
laboratory and our blood bank and the
cost was approximately 10% more and we
have found that that was totally
valuable for us we have no problem and
don't feel like that was a significant
cost in the big scheme of things thank
you
which we have one more question from an
audience number technology constantly
changes and seems to be the greatest
challenge for laboratories and all
businesses it appears that you've
created a structure that can easily
adapt to some of these changes however
with a limited budget is there any
advice you could give to other labs as
they begin to adopt their structures as
what as to what they should focus on
first like a primary focus various a lot
of various options that we were able to
take advantage of and I am very
fortunate that we had that flexibility I
would highly recommend that the raised
flooring if you're limited on where your
funding can go the raised floor for us
has been so beneficial and the
flexibility of the casework and I don't
see that the cost is as significant as
say putting in one of the columns or the
additional role so I think you may find
that you can balance some of that cost
without having additional now one of the
things that we found with the core lab
and the open concept that was probably a
challenge for us that we still deal with
is the sound and the sound absorption
that was one of the learning lessons
that we had we wish we had invested more
funding in sound absorption so we're
actually kind of paying for that now
because we're having to add cost in the
long run so I think if you spend the
money upfront for something like the
raised floor you'll find that your
long-term cost is a saving not an
addition
thank you so much for that Tammy do you
have any closing remarks you'd like to
share with the audience members before
we close today I'm giving me the
opportunity to be here today I have I
feel very fortunate to have had this
experience here at Geisinger to be able
to develop this new laboratory and have
had frequent visitors come and see our
location and experience what this
cutting-edge technology we have here and
the extra steps that we're able to
provide to the laboratory business I
think is a huge benefit because it gives
others the opportunity to learn from us
so we welcome that opportunity of things
I'd like to reach out to us and come
make a visit we would welcome you to be
there Tammy termini thank you again for
this valuable presentation I'd also like
to thank lab roots for making today's
educational webcast possible audience
members today's webcast will be
available for on-demand to August 2017
keep an eye out for an email from labrys
alerting you when the webcast will be
available for replay we encourage you to
forward that announcement to your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event thanks for joining us and
hope to see you again see you next time
goodbye